حطام متداخل وخليط من الطين والحجاره
والاخشاب هذا كل ما تبقى من قريه تيك اخت
المغربيه في اعالي جبال الاطلس بعد ان شهد
سكانها ليله عصيبه نتيجه قربها من بؤره
الزلزال المدمر في الثامن من سبتمبر
الجاري في هذا الركام اللامتناهي ذكريات
طفوله وقريه هدمت فوق رؤوس ساكنها 70 شخصا
قضوا نحبهم في ليله الزلزال بينهم اسر
باكملها
خويا ثلاثه
[موسيقى]
نفس الطريقه باش لقينا باش جبناهم ميتين
بالالاف واولادهم 58 شخصا فقط هم جلوا من
تبقى من اهالي القريه كانوا خارجها ليله
الزلزال وفق روايه السكان والناشطين
المحليين الذين التقينا بهم خلال جولتنا
في القريه
مئذنه هذا المسجد هي الشاهد الوحيد الذي
قد يروي تفاصيل الفاجعه بعد انهيار القريه
بشكل كامل واختفاء الطرقات التي كانت تربط
بين المنازل تحت ركامل الابنيه
[موسيقى]
اخبرني السيد عمر ان هذا المكان كان طريقا
رئيسا لاهالي القريه قريه الى المسجد الان
اصبحت
مليئه بالركام بالحجر وللوصول الى المسجد
الامر صعب جدا
عدد الضحايا الكبير في القريه البسيطه
اجبر من تبقى من سكانها على دفن جثامين
اقربائهم في مقابر جماعيه 70 شخص مدفون في
هذه البلاصه 70 شخص هنا
على حسب كل اكبر اخر اخر اخر
الناس اللي تقريبا بقوا يومين في تحت
الهدم هما هاد السيد رجل المراه
هادو هما اللي طخرو هاد الناس هادو السيد
ومرته هما اللي بقاو لنا يومين تحت الهدم
ديال المنازل فاش جبناهم انا درنا عليهم
ثلاثمائه متر هي مساحه هذه المقبره
الجماعيه في قريه كيخت هذه المساحه
الصغيره تضم 70 شخصا قضوا نحبهم في
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب المغرب الجمعه
الماضي الثامن من سبتمبر